cuántas veces han oído la frase
no tengo autoestima
o expresiones como
me falta autoestima
hay personas que van al psicólogo y
dicen cosas como
tengo ansiedad estoy triste y además
tengo la autoestima baja
como si la autoestima fue un elemento
más de nuestro cuerpo
veamos
glucosa bien triglicéridos estupendo
autoestima
tienes la autoestima baja
la autoestima
no existe
y si existe es tan solo una palabra
que recoge un conjunto amplio de
conductas verbales
me explico
la autoestima está formada por las
descripciones que hacemos de nosotros
mismos y nosotras mismas
yo puedo decir que soy guapa
que soy lista que soy buena
que soy tonta que soy fea que soy mala
todos y todas nos describimos
describimos aspectos de nuestra persona
y de nuestra vida
el problema es que las personas somos
tremendamente inexactas y a veces nos
montamos dramas que se nos van de
presupuesto
nos decimos cosas como
soy horrible no hago nada bien soy torri
soy terrible
no valgo para nada resuena
estas palabras estas conductas verbales
influyen
por un lado influyen en cómo nos
comportamos
si yo me digo que soy tonta es poco
probable que me apunté a ese curso oa
ese máster que llevo tanto tiempo
queriendo hacer
si me digo que no voy a conseguir nada
en la vida es poco probable que vaya a
esa entrevista porque total de que iba a
servir
si yo me hubiera dicho que no tengo nada
interesante que contar no estaría aquí
estas palabras estas conductas verbales
también influyen en cómo nos sentimos
si yo ustedes les digo que son
maravillosos que son maravillosas que
son guapísimos y guapísimas cómo se
sentirán
bien
quizá contentos qué maja la psicóloga
está
pero hoy si les digo que son unas
personas deleznables
inútiles
como sentirán
probablemente experimenten emociones
negativas
malestar quizá enfadado quizá algunas
personas estás en mis declaraciones de
intolerables
pero qué pasa si son ustedes mismos o
ustedes mismas quiénes están diciendo
estas barbaridades
a veces parece que las palabras son más
tolerables si provienen precisamente de
uno mismo de una misma
pero es muy peligroso caer en ese juego
si la descripción que hago de mí misma
está plagada de palabras negativas mis
emociones también serán negativas
hay personas que dicen cosas como
soy terrible tengo mal cuerpo y es que
además estoy triste
normal normal que una persona sienta
triste al decirse esto
si le echó leña al fuego avivó las
llamas y si me describo con palabras
negativas avivar en la tristeza
la tristeza
la depresión hay que tener cuidado con
estas palabras
nunca se han escuchado cosas como
no puedo hacerlo porque estoy triste
no puedo ir es que estoy muy deprimido
como si la tristeza fuera algo que nos
viene dado y que inevitablemente nos
incapacita
no es tan sencillo
la tristeza puede tener una explicación
conductual
me explico
imaginen
imagine por unos segundos cómo sería un
buen día un día de estos que terminan y
se dicen pues ha estado bien
probablemente imaginen que pasan el día
con los colegas que salen a tomar algo
que pasen un buen rato con su familia
quizá que hace una pequeña escapada a la
montaña a la playa
o quizás simplemente se imaginen en casa
tranquilamente leyendo
viendo una serie
y ahora imaginen
que durante un periodo de tiempo
prolongado no pueden hacer esas
actividades
y que además porque la vida es así
reciben malas noticias tiene disgustos
la tristeza
se explica por la pérdida por la
ausencia de situaciones que nos resultan
agradables placenteras
y por la presencia de situaciones que
nos resultan desagradables
y algo desagradable puede ser la muerte
de un familiar
un despido una discusión pero también
las palabras que nos decimos pueden ser
desagradables
si no estamos diciendo constantemente
que no vamos a conseguir nada en la vida
que no tenemos control sobre las cosas
si dejamos de salir si dejamos de buscar
trabajo si nos decimos que somos
terribles tendremos los ingredientes
perfectos para un rico plato de tristeza
y depresión
y es que en muchas ocasiones no es que
no podamos hacer algo porque estamos
tristes
es que estamos tristes porque no lo
hacemos
en ocasiones puede ocurrir que el
esfuerzo que tenemos que hacer para
realizar una determinada actividad es
mayor que la recompensa que esperamos
obtener
pero sólo se superamos esa pequeña
barrera inicial podremos experimentar
satisfacción placer y sólo entonces
queremos repetir esa actividad
ejemplo típico
a hacer deporte
empezará a correr
hay personas que se plantean
efectivamente hacer deporte pero no le
ven la gracia a eso de salir a correr y
sudar ponerse rojos bueno seamos
sinceros quizá no la tienen no lo sé
pero las personas que se lo plantean y
que hacen ese pequeño paso
hacer deporte un día
y otro día también
las personas transcurridos unos pocos
días empiezan a sentir
satisfacción
y transcurridos unos pocos días más
algunas personas empiezan a experimentar
una sensación parecida a la felicidad
en creer eso que tanto me desagradaba
ahora me gusta
pues esto pasa también con otras
actividades con muchas a lo mejor al
principio no me apetece salir a tomar un
café con los compañeros de trabajo
o no me apetece ir a clase de guitarra
clase manualidades pero si no lo hago
nunca poder experimentar la potencial
satisfacción que me puede reportar y que
además contribuiría a que me sintiera
menos triste
y sabiendo esto
qué podemos hacer para sentirnos mejor
en cuanto a la autoestima autoestima
recuerden que solo es una palabra lo que
podemos hacer es usar un lenguaje más
preciso no peyorativo y valorar las
cosas positivas tanto o más que las
cosas negativas
y dejar de hacer exageraciones
y ser más justos
típico ejemplo
personas que dicen
que soy un desastre todo me sale mal
todo
todo te sale mal
y cómo ha sobrevivido hasta ahora
cómo te alimentas entonces te sale más
del desayuno todo te sale mal
y como has llegado hasta aquí aclaró que
esos anuncios que hacen por la megafonía
del transporte público de tengan cuidado
de no introducir el pie entre coche y
andén los ponen por ti exclusivamente
basta ya de ser injustos con nosotros
mismos y con nosotras mismas
no somos un desastre simplemente a veces
no salen las cosas la primera
no somos horribles tenemos algunas
arrugas tenemos estrías y también
tenemos los ojos bonitos
no es que nada salga bien esta vez no ha
salido como yo esperaba pero la próxima
vez no saber qué ocurre si no lo intento
todo esto repercutirá en nuestro estado
de ánimo
si me valoro de forma más precisa no me
sentiré tan mal
y si me valora de forma positiva puede
que me sienta muy bien
pruébenlo
les reto a hacer valoraciones más justas
y más precisas
y también les reto a que superen esa
pequeña barrera inicial ya que hagan
actividades que se expongan a sentir
satisfacción
pueden sentirse mejor nosotros somos el
motor del cambio
siempre podemos encontrar mil excusas
para no hacer algo siempre podremos
encontrar mil defectos pero se puede
cambiar
y para ello recuérdenlo
simple pero muy potente
nuestra conducta es la clave
muchas gracias por su atención
[Aplausos]